delémont 5 en laye où si j'ai une date
c'est super monde de coulon chars la
tête de ma mère espèce de fils de deux
chiens la d2 ma mère tu vas être muji
avis je vais te manger
alors est-ce qu'elle a bien fait de
diffuser la wii oui moi je dis oui bien
sûr daniel way à moi je trouve
évidemment aurait pu en rester c'est
hyper chaud quand il rentre il ya dix
ans pour demandé de l'amener il prend le
sakhir pas c'est traumatisant mais va
pas dire est ce que je peux te prendre
les vittel moi je suis derrière ça fait
peur on est chez
moi ça m'a fait comme si ces agressions
informatiques les agressions elles font
peur et bien sûr et elle a raison c'est
un peu comme mon petit dauphin brest
malheureusement non mon départ oui mais
si quand on voit des actions comme ça je
suis dit c'est pas les mêmes hamedani
encore
je dis pas qu'il faut le protéger je dis
juste que ce qu'elle a fait est illégal
c'est youtube donc tu ne
il a fait cela détermine mon problème tu
ne tue ne lutte pas contre quelques une
action illégale on est en toi même dans
l'illégalité
la vidéo tu la donnes aux flics et les
flics bon marché tu fais pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
totalement raison le sac elle s'est fait
voler vos dix sept mille euros est là
pour soixante mille euros en tout et le
problème c'est que quand vous faites
voler des objets de luxe comme ça vous
porter plainte si vous avez de la chance
vous fait rembourser une partie par les
assurances et il se passe rien et où ils
ont rien donc là ça peut aider aussi à
médiatiser la faire à faire peut-être
avant celle enquête donc évidemment
qu'elle a raison d une fois ça nous
avait pas une question d'argent même 15
cas qui se fait péter un sac à samba
dedans il ya ton téléphone il résulte
des enfants c'est pas une question de
17000 honte a volé un sac mais ce qu'il
a fait si légal il a joué il est rentré
dans un magasin il arrache un sac si
elle veut mettre sa photo et qu'on voit
sa tête tant pis pour lui maintenant
faut assumer tu as fait quelque chose
d'illégal elle a fait quelque chose
d'illégal qu'est ce qu'on va arrêter de
protéger les délinquants moi je n'en
peux plus vous voyez là toutes les
nouvelles sur ses pas il faut
privilégier l'idée d'arrêter l'ailé il
faut changer les lois si c'est la loi
elle est pas bonne il faut la changer on
n'est plus dans le même monde cette
toile a peut-être été fait il ya 30 ans
quand il y avait pas toute cette
violence il faudrait évoluer aussi où il
évolue il faut qu'on évolue et je suis
désolé on peut être en fait je comprends
ce que dit valent mais on peut aussi
être contre les lois actuelles ça veut
dire que ça va parce qu'il ya des lois
on peut pas se dire ouais mais en fait
on n'est pas d'accord avec la loi et le
fait de divulguer le visage de la
personne bas comme si guillaume
peut-être que oui ça peut aider après à
se dire bah on va éviter à ce que les
gens fassent la loi tout seul et on va
peut être activé et aller plus vite dans
les enquêtes parce que généralement les
gens au final mais il récupère pas grand
chose et ils sont dégoûtés à se passer
la balle magique on imagine quelqu'un
imagine quelqu'un le reconnaît le type
se fait lyncher qu'est ce qui se passe
pour comment elle s'appelle la jeune
fille mais qu'est ce qui se passe pour
elle qui a mis ce type est pas sur les
réseaux cette substance qu à la jambe
non non non rien on a retrouvé le mec le
thème que dans d'autres matchs il un jeu
tête à d'autres mais qui voudront aller
voler des salles et qui diront que
j'arrête
peut-être qu'il a frappé une dame âgée à
van persie a commis d'autres méfaits on
ne sait pas en revanche ce qui est
illégal c'est que la boutique est donné
les imageries bah oui ça c'est illégal
bien sûr maintenant qu'elle est mis sur
les réseaux c'est son problème oui non
mais la victime s'est elle on est bien
d'accord et ce qui est passé est
choquant e traumatisant mais affiché
quelqu'un ça veut dire passer outre la
loi vidéosurveillance personnes sont des
gens habilités des policiers des
enquêteurs ont le droit de visionner
donc effectivement on n'a pas le droit
d'afficher sinon pour répondre à raymond
il ya plus à daniel il ya plus à ce
moment il n'y a plus aucun respect des
règlements et à dire on est attaqué
c'est me répond de la même manière mais
non
répond sans respecter les lois ou alors
que sinon on n'est plus dans une société
c'est bien qu'on lui tire dessus alors
dont tu proposes quoi qu'on me tire
dessus daniel ne pas du tout simplement
comme un jeu et je veux qu'on montre les
gens qui font des choses comme ça marche
mal
protégé j'en ai marre quand on voit par
exemple des violeurs d'enfants avec ça
qu'ils sont qui sont protégés mais jean
valjean te plus on est jeune on a lâché
andy pas content c'est vous voulez vous
nous avez tous les jours une baisse qui
a non mais ça vous choque pas qu'on
emmenait ça vous chante pas qu'on montre
d une loi très récente ciré la
vidéosurveillance ça n'existait pas
beaucoup bug pas la changer c'est fait
pour protéger à ce moment là sinon mais
les images à ce moment-là privées de
vidéosurveillance de vidéoprotection
pour être diffusée partout et il n'y a
plus d'intimité des gens